بالكاد تتنفس ،
بالكاد تصيح الكلمات التي
تحترق أرض
والدها ، دعها تحترق.
قرية
على الساحل الجنوبي للبحر الأبيض المتوسط لتركيا ، يب
و الأمر كما لو كانوا يقاتلون وح
ًا يستمر في الحياة في كل
رة يجرؤون على أمل موته ، كل
يء سيحرق كا
جا يخبرنا بحزن أن أر
نا حيواناتنا منزلنا ما
ا لدينا أيضًا على ال
غم من  كونه قريبًا من
الوجهات السياحية الساحلية الشهيرة ،
لا يمتلك هؤلاء القرويون الكثير ، وما
لديهم من
اعتزاز ، يفخرون به في
مجموعة صغيرة من الرجال من هنا في
مناطق أخرى يتنقلون عبر
الحقول القابلة للاشتعال بسهولة
التي يتحكمون فيها في خرطوم رجال الإطفاء.
تشعر بالحرارة وكأن الماء
يتبخر بنفس السرعة
التي يتم بها رشها ، حيث تم العثور
على الأشجار لمنع ألسنة اللهب من النمو
وتطاير الشرر إلى مناطق أخرى.
مرحبًا ، يقاتلون وحشًا قد لا
يتمكنون من التغلب
على آخر الأطفال ، يتم إرسالهم بعيدًا ،
كيف يجب أن أشعر أننا لم ننم لمدة
ثلاثة أيام هذا الصباح يبدأ هذا الصباح بإخبارنا
كيف يشعرون بما
يفكرون فيه  مثير للسخرية تمامًا
وأنا أحصل عليه لما يمكن للمرء أن
يفكر فيه حتى يقول عندما يشاهدون
كل ما يمتلكونه في الحياة على
وشك أن يحترق أروى دامون
سيينا
مانافكا تركيا